the thing is like women have a choice a
lot of men don't
because a lot of men are short they're
unattractive like that's just i mean i'm
not saying just but it is scary for
women as well to create a family in
these days with these kind of men
there's a lot of men are behaving like
women and women are behaving like men
right so we are chasing the bag yes
because we met a lot of men they are
just like [ __ ] boys you know and they
just wanted they they pretend to lure
you in with you know presents and love
bombing but you realize like we we
choose the men that are [ __ ] boys we
choose them because we we overlook 80
percent of men
we overlook there's a there's a
so how many [ __ ] boys in your
percentages you know
how many what do you know how many [ __ ]
ways are out there and many good okay
okay guys out there when i say
let me know i'm interested so when i let
me know where when i think of a [ __ ] boy
i think of a guy that's talking and
sleeping with multiple girls right would
you say that's what you would define
okay uh i had a [ __ ] why he was only
sleeping with me but okay and he become
you wanted to yeah sorry because he was
standing 24 7 with me so uh definitely
he was only sleeping with me no menage a
trois no no threesome
how is he a fuckboy then yeah i need to
know this
the behavior because sometimes
for example we would go out and he would
try to make me jealous or playing like
mind games okay so he's crazy so he's
not [ __ ] okay so [ __ ] boy he's
[ __ ] pretty people only that when i
think when i think about
when i think of a [ __ ] boy i think of
a guy that's sleeping with multiple
women like that's because when i when
yeah he was a [ __ ] boy before he met me
he told me like he was [ __ ] every
every other girl every weekend yes so so
that's so what i'm saying so what i'm
saying is there's a very small
percentage of men that have the
opportunity to do that so for example if
you want a guy that's i'm six foot i
would prefer a guy that's taller than me
i mean if i want a guy that's taller
than me that's 15 of the population
let's say half of those guys are broke
because let's say let's say half a rich
half are broke that's another half
that's that's so half of 15 is 7.5
percent right so that's 7.5 percent of
the you're looking for
and it's probably even smaller than that
so what i'm saying is we pick and that's
that's a superficial thing right looking
for height that's super fit it's okay i
like it too i'm not no yeah no shame i
get it like a rock you can apply but but
we me and you if we wanted we could pick
a short king that would be faithful to
us but we just choose not to
so i can't put it on the men if we're
the ones picking those guys and we're
all picking the same guys
yeah it's like you're blocking our own
blessing really yeah by
overlooking what you might not go for
for what you would normally go for so
yeah we kind of like hindered ourselves
yeah
yeah and so i like i have a lot of
empathy because i i think a lot of girls
don't know this
yeah yeah like that's what
yeah i mean i feel like there's this
thing being pushed
um on social media and
it's like the the sort of like hookup
culture and and the
the sort of
advice that girls are given that they
should go out and experiment a lot and
sort of like get to know what they like
and i feel like by the point that you
finish feeling like you you got to know
what you like you actually got to know
what you don't like and by that i mean
like you experience things that left you
traumatized and left you with a lot of
baggage that
you're gonna you know take on to your
next relationships like
and
and you know take it out on guys um that
don't deserve it like i've personally
experienced this and in the sense that
one guy like you know turns out to be a
[ __ ] boy and then like i just feel like
this need of like revenge with like the
rest of like the male population like
you know i i feel like it's it's a
natural thing and like obviously i know
that it's not
you know it's not valid and like i've
i've worked through that but um and that
way i feel like that did harm me you
know and and sometimes i wish that i
wouldn't like have bought into that like
oh just go out and get to know what you
like because
you don't really need to like
it's uh i think it's more fun i guess i
guess we actually focus on the minority
that actually posts in social media that
and then we relate all of with all of
them like oh my gosh she's a girl she
had this case i have the same i'm
feeding her and like we all like
generalize that the whole world is like
that is negative everyone is just bad
just by focusing on the minority that
are highlighting their experiences over
social media but we forget that there is
a majority that maybe did not are not
like that and did not face whatever
these people have faced right and maybe
there there are good people some
somewhere but just because we focus on
what is superficial as you said and we
focus on these people that had maybe we
can relate with them maybe you know when
these posts come out in your field and
be like oh have you been teaching now
and have you been blah blah blah we just
focus on that instead of focusing that
maybe we have other people that are good
and haven't had that and can't harm me
either so that's how maybe we just look
at the like negative side instead of
just um we just overlook at the negative
side basically instead of just looking
at a bright side yeah
and just because of the way the
algorithm works in social media usually
the stories that are pushed out are like
the most like extreme exactly you know
what i mean so we feel like we're
getting the whole picture but we're
actually not we're getting like the
minority that is like extreme cases
and i think that
feminism
it could have been done so much better
and with like telling women about these
stats instead of saying chase the bag
all about women women and women instead
of and they should have told women about
these stats like if you want this high
value man or blah blah blah blah
whatever it is saying like there's a
small pot be realistic
you need the if you want a family if you
want to have this
lifestyle white picket fence all that
good stuff realistically by 30 if you
don't have it you're
ex the
the um the image is going to get smaller
and smaller because
after 30
clock is ticking clock is ticking and
this that little small
small stat i think would have changed
the mind of a lot of women instead of
i'm just gonna focus on my career
everything and then i'll focus on
relationship and teaching them how to
balance things i think a lot of women
would be further along in their careers
and their lives and everything in their
happiness if
feminism if that movement was more
truthful and honest up front with how
can we be
our like a woman but also succeed be
successful in all these areas and come
out happy on the end instead of just
saying bump all men we're the best
species in the world and this is how we
become the best species it's like we
both need each other men and women both
need each other to exist i think that it
just could have been yeah i actually
believe also that because this thing
that the clock is ticking right and then
women oh this 30s 30s they end up
actually choosing drunk person and then
when they choose the wrong person and
have the
like most miserable experience in their
lives they actually think that everyone
is just like that
but they do not actually realize that
there are so many circumstances that
push them to choose the wrong person
first of all it's just this whole thing
oh the clock is ticking i don't have
time anymore and i need to rush i need
so whatever comes in that picture you
just choose that person and maybe end up
in the wrong situation that would
actually just give them the whole
picture of everything is wrong well i
think they're rushed because they didn't
prioritize marriage right exactly yeah
they made that choice and so then it's
like
as a woman like i just think when you're
and i say this like you know i'm not
married and i and i feel and i'm 25. and
and i it's like because as a woman you
know you you only have so much time and
if you wait too long and you don't pick
somebody like you're gonna end up not
having kids and to me like my life would
be purposeless if i didn't have kids it
would be to me it's like who cares about
a good career if you don't have someone
to share it with i feel like it's such a
double-edged sword though because yeah
when you're out looking for a partner
like the last thing you want to be is
desperate you know what i mean like the
last thing you want to do is go out
there with this fear-based mentality
that the clock is sticking like i have
to prioritize this because
you know like that's not gonna get you
the results that you want either
that's actually gonna make it worse you
know so so it's a balance you know on
one hand it's like you can't be like oh
yeah i just focus on my career in my 20s
and then like in my 30s like the right
man will appear because you know that
that's a fantasy and but also on the
other hand you can't just like be out
there being like the clock is sticking
where am i man you know what i mean i
think it's i think it's like dating with
intention
so like like i i don't know about you
but i have definitely wasted time with
with a guy that i knew was not my
husband i'm there i i have a hundred
percent done that because i was too
attached and i didn't want to leave yeah
yeah and so
then it's like we get closer and closer
to our 30s like let's say 35 like after
35 your chance of kids is tough like
that's that's when it becomes a
geriatric pregnancy and the average um i
know they talk about ivf but the average
person doesn't have 25 000 laying around
to do it
so for the average person it's basically
over at 35.
so
we waste our 20s with these guys we
shouldn't be with and then expect our
our husbands to pick up the pieces after
yeah yeah yeah and that's not really
fair to them because you know if we
overlook those guys in our 20s and then
say oh here i am at like 30 something
damage please take me
don't don't get me wrong some of y'all
still do
but it's not like a good way to go into
a marriage and i i'm not like i don't
you know i don't think we should all be
married at like 18 but i think there's
some balance because your options this
is another thing they don't tell you
your options decrease by 50 by the time
you're 30. so if they took your dating
app matches when you were
20 versus 30 it's 50 less by the time
you're 30. i'm just going to give up by
this time i ain't trying i'm closing
yeah that's where i
have a fellow
clock ticker because i am over 30. i
could definitely like over 30. oh wow
girl i would give you 25.
yes
so yeah i definitely like agree with a
lot of the points that you guys have
said that since i turned 30 there
definitely is like in the back of my
mind
what you doing girl like literally don't
have all the time in the world but then
in my 20s
i enjoyed playing the field dating and
seeing what happens but i do think that
it's a shame that
it's like you said there should be a
balance you shouldn't see it as just one
or the other because some people see
success
being making money others see it through
family through friends whatever you yes
classes if so i definitely agree there
should be some sort of narrative where
you know you can actually
have it all if you
are willing to invest that time into it
i don't think you can have it all i
think that's the lie that feminism says
you think i think you can have it
who but not at the same time no i i just
like okay i think you can have it all
but like gradually yeah moderation
moderation no i think that's i know
life's about trade-offs and choices so
like i grew up in a one percent family
like my parents are like very well off
my my mom um and my dad met young they
married they had they have 10 kids
and on paper they have it all but what
you don't see is you know there's
choices and trade-offs that came with it
i didn't see my dad for a lot of my
childhood right i didn't see my mom for
a lot of my childhood they worked so
much and that was a trade-off it's fine
i don't have college debt so i'm fine
with it but
but
you know we tell we tell women that
there's no trade-off and you can just
have everything and that's a one percent
of the population that did and they
barely did
and you know and even with your talking
about playing the field
that you know what the consequence for
playing the field is if you're a virgin
when you get married your chance of a
happy marriage is is around
i'm butchering this but around 80
percent these statistics
and if you if you have
if you sleep with more than five people
it goes down to 25 jesus
so your chances
five people yeah over five people it
goes down to twenty five percent fifty
well it's because like think about it
when you've experienced more men like
you compare the next guy to him
so your husband like like each guy each
guy you sleep with you might think oh i
liked that about him i liked that about
him i liked that about him and then the
next guy
he has all these standards to live up to